Jeff the drunk is on the air in New York
yes Jeff why do I feel I'm never picked
up on here's the reason you never get
your picked up because you're boring you
called to say you always call to go boy
cuz you call a boy because because you
call in and go how come I'm not on this
show anymore instead of calling him was
something interesting in fact Shirley
told me a whole list of topics you
brought up that you wanted to get on the
air and you could and they were horrible
Howard every time he calls in I look at
the screen and I see what his topic is
and I write it down yeah now you're
gonna know why I don't pick up here's
your topics and tell me if you would
pick up okay Jeff number one he once
called in and his topic was his nickname
in high school was Skippy that was a
topic you wanted to talk to you but why
do I care no how about you missed this
one how he didn't pick on this one we
called in on Wednesday to say have a
good weekend let's assume you had a
radio show that was really popular and
there was a guy on the phone who wanted
to say have a good weekend would you
pick up on him okay you might got me all
right October 20 19 was the classic are
you mad at me right which is the same as
why don't you pick up anymore and then
for a while I had to invent a character
called the lump that would call in and
goof on Jeff and he hated it then I
finally made you interesting and then
you [ __ ] complained about that where
is the lump let me see if he can help
out it lump where have you been I'm not
even calling it anymore I'm bored you
don't even call him when Jeff calls him
and you're the lump of flesh on his neck
that we couldn't really determine what
you were except that you were a lump
yeah I was real billion 2015 40 sucks
how do we get this Toronto virus can we
apply for it just the lump is even
Borbon you bend over backwards for a
ball ball you don't know that Jeff
that's you
I can't believe someone's jealous of
elbow why is it so important you to get
on the show okay yeah you write an essay
about what you need to be on the show I
like that idea
brilliant what write an essay on why you
will have to be on the show and it
should be 500 words oh my god I'm read
it tomorrow is that cutting into your
nothing you got planned today I do why
I'm okay I'll do it good
okie dokie